je vous l'avais promis et ben voilà
c'est aujourd'hui je reçois mon première
invitée qui vient nous parler de sa
particularité physique et il s'agit de
greg romano c'est monsieur romano
monsieur greg romano voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
greg romano et auteur comédien humoriste
stand-up heures youtuber et manquent de
golden moustache
bonjour monsieur dray grand nano alors
quelle est la particularité physique bas
particularité physique je suis grand g
les membres ip relaxe j'ai fait tout mon
père et j'ai le dos opéré j'ai le coeur
opérer et je me suis fait des fractures
environ tous les doigts de la main
fracturée intense et les poignets aussi
et les cheveux ça c'est lié à quoi même
à l'asie qui est le syndrome de marfan
qui je suis hyper laxiste et démembré en
fait ça attaque plusieurs organes du
corps notamment le coeur les poumons le
dos ça c'est vraiment les trois plus
grosses parties et donc j'ai été opéré
des 3 par rapport à ça comment est-ce
que tu as découvert que tu avais un truc
différent des autres
ben j'ai eu un coup de bol en fait dans
mon malheur il était en train de mixer
en boîte et j'ai une douleur au coeur à
l'époque je me rappelle j'enchaînais et
la boîte de nuit le lendemain matin je
faisais le morning à la radio du fel aux
urgences et là je suis allé offert une
éco cardiaque nous avez ne croque avec
portable c'est le petit défaut cardiaque
emma disque usé moi mais comme vous êtes
gros on voit pas trop donc il faudrait
que vous alliez vraiment à l'hôpital
saint-antoine pour faire une vraie
cardiaque
donc c'est en faisant l'écho cardiaque
qu'on a vu que j'avais une dissection
aortique et là en fait la douleur que
j'avais était une douleur qui n'avait
rien à voir avec la dissection aortique
donc c'est là où j'ai eu de la chance
parce que si je n'étais pas aller
justement sur l'éco cardiaque
je serais sûrement pas là en ce moment
moi j'ai été opérée sur trois jours
après après ils ont commencé à faire les
tests génétiques et avec les jeunes ils
sont beaux ils ont confirmé que c'était
un enfant
le syndrome de marfan c'est une maladie
qui touche une certaine forme de nos
tissus qui soutient nos organes qu'on
appelle le tissu conjonctif la cause
généralement c'est une protéine qui le
composent qu'on appelle la fibrine un
qui n'est plus produite correctement et
c'est un pédiatre français du nom
d'antoine marfan qu'il a identifiées en
1896 et c'est une maladie génétique qui
touche environ 12
personne en france tous sexes confondus
donc on a une visite tous les tous les
deux ans à l'hôpital bichat qui est le
centre marsan de référence donc il nous
faut une batterie de tests c'est à dire
est qu cardiaque respiration voie aux
cimes si une généticienne un cardiologue
et en fait on s'est tous les tests à
chaque fois et en plus de ça moi j'ai
une consultation cardio tous les six
mois jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
le syndrome de marfan dilate l'aorte qui
est l'artère qui sort du coeur pour
envoyer le sang oxygéné tous nos organes
grâce à ses ramifications
c'est un peu la maman toutes les artères
comme la paroisse est fragilisée par la
dilatation elle risque de se disloquer
et de se rompre
du coup aux premiers signes on opère en
urgence on fait donc une opération qui
consiste en fait à mettre une valise
mécanique qu'on a tous une valve d'un
corps qui envoie le sens aux organes et
donc moi l'avait levé tendance à
s'écarter
donc ils m'ont mis une autre et on a le
choix entre une valve mécanique ou une
valve animal la valve animal
l'avantagent qu'elle a c'est qu'on est
obligé de prendre des médicaments à vie
l'inconvénient c'est qu'elle a une durée
de vie limitée alors que la valve
mécanique l'avantagent qui est là c'est
qu'elle a une durée de vie illimitée
on doit prendre des médicaments toutes
sa vie et on entend un clic clac
dans son torse toutes les secondes oui
donc là c'est pas ta montre qu'on entend
en fait c'est ça non la v1
spondylolisthésis parce qu'on dit löw
lise qui est un glissement de vertèbres
entre l5 donc la dernière étape es11 le
sacrum donc ils me l'ont remis ils m'ont
mis des vis pour tenir c'est marrant ce
quand je fais les radios on voit
vraiment lévis et c'est impressionnant
l'impression de partie c'est ces radios
ou le gars est fait je sais pas comment
cette bouteille de perrier est arrivé
dans mon cul je voulais vraiment que ça
et mon mais aussi un espèce de barbelés
au milieu et je me suis fait opérer
aussi de pneumothorax don qui est le
poumon qui se décollent de la plèvre
après une fois que ça m'arrivait je me
rappelle j'étais en train de faire un
ping pong avec une fille que je voulais
draguer et je commence à jouer au ping
pong où je peux j'ai vraiment plus à
respirer est en panique parce que
j'avais un bon pression de m'étouffer
donc je suis allé aux urgences et leur
madiop de moteurs axe donc on m'a opéré
et moi comme je n'aime pas faire les
choses à moitié j'ai fait le deuxième
deux semaines après et de l'autre côté
de l'autre côté way et là ce qui était
cool c était que je me suis fait opérer
le 13 juillet 1998 donc le lendemain de
la coupe du monde donc le soir de la
coupe du monde en fait je les regardais
dans le lit d'hôpital mes fils et un
médicament pour aller bien aux toilettes
pour avant l'opération
c'est quand même pu voir les trois buts
le voilà tous mes potes faisait la fête
dehors et moi j'étais à l'hôpital alors
j'allais faire opérer demain
j'ai fait une petite déprime pendant un
an quand même jouer le contre coup je me
suis rendu compte de ce qui s'était
passé maintenant apprécié le quotidien
as et des médicaments tout le temps je
dois vraiment vérifié d'éviter tout ce
qui est l'infection
je dois faire tous les six mois je veux
faire un détartrage des dents parce que
c'est vrai que les dents soit un foyer
d'infection
tout comme moi j'aime bien les tatouages
c'est pas très conseillé
mais avant de faire un tatouage à chaque
fois je prends trois grammes
antibiotiques
avant j'ai été nommé parrain de la sauce
du marchand et je me rends compte il ya
beaucoup de gens qui viennent me parler
sur facebook qui ont un enfant et qui
ont besoin d'être rassurés et j'essaie
de les aider à mon niveau
parce que c'est vrai que j'avais cette
angoisse au début j'ai jamais voulu
faire des réunions marfan au début les
deux premières années je le fils hors de
question que je rencontre d'autres
personnes qui ont la maladie parce que
ça m'a un peu traumatisé et petit à
petit j'ai commencé à y aller pour
assurer des personnes qui le sont pas
encore qui n'ont pas encore été opérés
ou qui vont ont déjà été opérées jeu ça
me fait plaisir de le faire
j'ai l'impression d'apporter ma petite
pierre à l'édifice puis à ton spectacle
aussi ouais mon spectacle dans la
première version gens parler un petit
peu et là j'ai vraiment décidé de faire
un siècle entier devant donc sur la
maladie et sur l'opération du coeur en
elle-même et comment je les ai vécus et
oui c'est ma c'est ma thérapie à moi je
me suis opéré le 3 juin 2008 et j'ai
commencé à écrire mon spectacle et c'est
marrant parce que la première fois qu'on
a qu'on m'a diagnostiqué donc cette
dissection aortique c'était le 27 mai il
se trouve que la prend fin de ma vie où
je suis monté sur scène pour faire une
scène ouverte c'était un 27 mai et la
première fois de ma vie où j'ai joué mon
spectacle en entier c'était un trois
joueurs et je me suis offert 1 3 juin et
je n'ai pas fait exprès mais je me dis
moi et je suis très signe très jours et
donc à partir de ce moment là où il
commence à aller sur scène pour raconter
tout ça je ne sais pas ça mais ça m'a
fait ma thérapie à moi et et le fait
aussi de partager d'expliquer aussi
cette maladie au aux autres personnes ça
me fait du bien en fait maintenant
parler les personnes atteintes du
syndrome de marfan sont généralement
très grande mais les manifestations sont
différentes d'une personne à l'autre et
elles ont pas tout tous les symptômes
quand tu l'a appris est ce que tu te
souviens la première chose à laquelle tu
as quand c'est en fait le moment où j'ai
appris le syndrome que j'avais seulement
de marfan m'a rien fait parce que je me
doutais que j'allais la voir
je crois que c'est le jour où j'ai
appris je vais me faire opérer du coeur
c'est ça qui m'a vraiment
on peut déstabiliser ce que je me
rappelle ça c'est fait d'une mauvaise
façon j'étais à l'hôpital saint-antoine
il y avait une interne qui m'avait fait
une éco cardiaque et en faisant les
contiendrait qu'elle a vraiment fait un
an et je dis mais qu'est ce qui se passe
et tout je peux pas vous le dire elle
était ressortie elle était revenue avec
une autre interne elle avait remontera
l'écho cardiaque en mode le regarde je
l' ai découvert quoi c'est moi qui ai
découvert ça et je dis petit mois ce qui
a aidé où elle m'a dit je peux rien vous
dire mais je pense que vous allez le
faire opérer du coeur en urgence là les
sorties de la salle elle m'a laissé un
quart d'heure moi bien sûr
bah je chiale et je vais pour appeler ma
mère en fait et je captais pas dans la
houle se faisait l'écho cardiaque à
saint antoine
bon je suis resté comme ça dans la
chambre tout seul en mode
ok là je vais me faire opérer du coeur
et après une médecin qu'est venu
adorable qui m'a expliqué tout ça
gentiment et c'est marrant parce que
qu'ils leur vie a pas longtemps elle est
venue 1 et spectacle et ça m'a
énormément touché en fait de la revoir
parce que on se rend pas compte des fois
mais à l'hôpital
le côté humain est très important au
delà du côté médecine
je pense que c'est quand même très
importants et des fois le problème c'est
que certains services les gens ne s'en
rendent pas compte en fait de la
détresse que certains peuvent avoir et
le besoin d'être rassuré dans la
majorité des cas le syndrome de marfan
est héréditaire c'est à dire que ce sont
les parents qui sont porteurs du gène et
qu'ils transmettent à leurs enfants
mais le gène peut aussi subir une
mutation spontanée comme dans le cas de
règles je suis le premier de ma famille
et avoir le marsan prem's c'est moi mais
par contre s'il ya un enfant elle a une
chance sur deux de la voir donc c'est en
ça maintenant j'essaie d'être assuré moi
je me suis rassuré pour moi maintenant
je m'inquiète pour mon futur enfant je
veux pas qu'il est je veux pas qu'il est
je veux pas qu'ils souffrent je vais pas
qu'ils vivent avec ça c'est à dire que
si la le marchand ce sera un médicament
dès sa naissance et toute sa vie donc ça
je veux pas enfin de me renseigner par
rapport à la génétique pour savoir
quelle est la meilleure solution en fait
pour pour moins souffrir en face que
mentalement et physiquement surtout pour
moi
ma future femme ça va être compliqué
pour moi mentalement et pour elle et
mentalement et physiquement
j'essaie de me rassurer là dessus mais
moi ça va je me suis rassuré dans
génération meilleur avec faut essayer de
voir le verre à moitié plein moi c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire pour ça c'est
bizarre ce que d'habitude dans la vie
qui commence un peu à voir le verre à
moitié vide
mais pour cette même pour la maladie
justement j'ai j'ai un côté plutôt
positif et l'essai de bien le prendre et
je me rends compte
après c'est compliqué les maladies sont
différentes mais moi je le vis beaucoup
mieux en fait depuis que je suis positif
par rapport à cette maladie et j'essaie
de voir je me dis ah toujours pire il ya
toujours pire à côté donc voilà j'essaie
d'être positif et voilà tout simplement
positif et voir le verre à moitié plein
puis par amina saucisses appel marfan
qu'a changé n'ya pas longtemps et qui
est une très bonne assise qui s'occupe
voilà il faut il faut vraiment venir on
fait des réunions une fois par an faut
se renseigner mois n'hésitez pas à
m'envoyer un message sur facebook je
vous envoie tous les liens mais c'est
une nation qui va beaucoup aider moi qui
m'a dit m'a donné beaucoup
d'informations qui m'a expliqué la
maladie au plus profond et voilà c'est
bien essayé c'est bien aussi de se
réunir entre entre gens malades et de
discuter de tout ça en plus si vous
venez la journée le matin on a
croissants et pains au chocolat à
volonté avec du café ça franchement
c'est cool et apprendre à leur pack et
gratuit donc ça c'est bien pareil pour
ça moi j'ai de bonne facture mais en
plus les croissances en très bon bon
coeur entre autres on vous mettra leur
vous le traduire dans la dans la
description des deux
généralement toutes les maladies c'est
vrai que comme le dit greg le plus
important c'est pas rester tout seul
dans son coin et d'en parler avec des
gens de préférence des gens qui savent
ce qu'on est en train de vivre parce que
c'est quand même une grosse partie du
grosse partie des pink on se retire du
pied quand on en parle avec l'esa et non
parlez surtout pas son optimum vraiment
faire pareil les gens qui connaissent
cette fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]